and I see a hand reach down to me I kind
of reached up to it and I kind of took
that as if it was uh let's go
hey guys I'm Kelsey rose and today I'm
gonna tell you my er horror story
I was probably about 14 or 15 it was
Thanksgiving and we just finished dinner
everything was great all of a sudden I
felt this really sharp pain in my tummy
so I was like in the fetal position in
the bathroom my mom comes in back sorry
I hate the ER I hate going to doctors so
when I told her I thought I needed to go
to the ER she knew something was wrong
we finally go in and the doctor starts
doing the initial exam very bluntly
she's like are you sexually active I'm
like there with my mom you know it's
like very uncomfortable I'm not pregnant
cuz I knew that's where he was going
with it he's like all right I'm gonna do
like some blood work goes off he comes
back with a pregnancy test so I did it
what does it say not pregnant the doctor
comes in again with another pregnancy
test
we just want a double check so again go
pee on it not pregnant boo I told you so
then he's like alright well we're gonna
take you in to get an ultrasound because
we think you might have an ectopic
pregnancy and I'm like I'm not pregnant
I go in and I'm like laying down and the
woman just squirts there like gel on me
and it's freezing cold like there's no
oh hey by the way this might be
uncomfortable so they do the ultrasound
oh surprise I don't have an ectopic
pregnancy at this point we're like five
hours into this ordeal from seeing the
doctor so like seven hours later right
then the doctor is like off his shift so
a new doctor comes in and he's like
looking at the chart and I'm like yep
not pregnant he's like alright well
we're gonna do another ultrasound to see
if your appendix is burst you mean I've
been like sitting in this ER with like
an appendix I could have just be like
rupturing and I go in for my second
ultrasound with the same really jolly
nurse guess what my appendix has not
burst but this doctor was not convinced
so they're like we're actually gonna
keep you overnight I'm like dude it's
5:00 in the morning I've been here
overnight
the guy goes we're gonna see in the
morning if you're not feeling better
we're gonna do emergency surgery
she all said I was pregnant now you want
to like roll me in a surgery without
confirming that like my appendix is
burst my mom quickly gets on the phone
and calls one of her really good friends
who's an ER doctor and he's like T oh no
way in the morning a new doctor comes in
so it's been three doctors and he's like
okay we're not doing emergency surgery
this is crazy and by that time my mom's
friend is an ER doctor shows up gives me
a bye okay
turns out I'm all good to go because all
I had to do was now I don't need as much
something assuming and that is my er
horror story
hey I'm Rebecca and this is my er horror
story I was in college about two years
ago and when I got to English class I
saw that my teacher had a movie
projected on the screen I sit down and I
start watching the film but suddenly I
start to feel this weird feeling I think
back to the sandwich that I just had
before class am I gonna throw this up
right now like it didn't taste bad when
I originally ate it so I go to the
bathroom just to be sure I'm in the
bathroom for a few seconds and then
suddenly I lean over the toilet and I
start puking and I think okay I'm done
with that that was horrific let me just
keep watching this film just a few
seconds later I start feeling nauseous
again why I felt like I got it all out I
run to the bathroom but at this point I
can't stop
I keep puking over and over and over
could have a salmon sandwich actually
caused this I pull out my phone and I
call my mom because she actually works
at the ER nearby my house
she comes to pick me up from school and
takes me to the ER I still feel so
nauseous so I go into the bathroom of
the waiting area and start puking people
start coming inside because I forgot to
lock the door and they see me on my
knees holding the toilet looking like
death finally the nurse comes and takes
me to the hospital bed and when I look
at the nurse he's the most sexy guy I've
ever seen in my life and I'm looking
terrible my face is really pale I'm so
nervous
as this great guy next to me he puts me
in bed and he gives me an IV which is
amazing because after about 10 minutes
I'm feeling so much better my first
reaction is to start flirting with him
because he's so cute
but I looked
and I felt terrible so as you can
imagine it didn't end in a date that
really sucked and I had so many people
see me in the worst state that have ever
been in my life and that's my er Horror
Story hi I'm Brian and this is my er
Horror Story so I've been having this
pain in my stomach for almost a month
and I had no idea what it was thought it
was just guys one day I get up and I go
into the kitchen and I collapse to the
floor cuz the pain in my stomach was
just unbearable at this point my cousin
of course I was joking and she was like
oh my god I get up I look I can't can
you call my mom and get her down here
my mom came down she was telling me get
up get up and I couldn't so she was okay
we're taking to the hospital I mean once
we got to the hospital they came and
they got me in a wheelchair put me in
there and they did the x-ray they
noticed that there was nothing there
they won an injected toradol which I had
no idea what it was so as the doctor was
putting it into my IV it just started
feeling weird he's like oh no yeah it's
just that you know liquid painkiller I'm
like no no this feels really weird and
as he was finishing up I started kind of
like slouching into my seat and my eyes
closed and I couldn't speak and then I
started kind of shaking a little bit so
my mom got up right now and she started
calling doctors and nobody was around my
cousin got up and she started rolling me
around screaming hello somebody help me
somebody help me I could hear everything
but I didn't know what was going on
around me at this point I started
slouching even more and everything just
started getting kind of muffled and then
they finally after I don't even know how
long it took me into another room throw
me on the bed and they started slapping
me as if that was gonna wake me up as if
I wasn't trying to wake up the whole
time all of a sudden I just felt like a
bunch of people around me this is the
weird part that always kind of gets me
so I have my eyes closed and I'm laying
there and I see these clouds and I see a
hand reached down to me I kind of
reached up to it and I kind of took that
as if it was uh let's go the weirdest
thing is I was okay with it
but then all of a sudden right when I
reached up it went food disappeared and
all I saw was just like angels flying
around me and then I woke up in my house
and
morning and I was like I moms like you
you don't know what I'm like how did I
get from the hospital to my bed she was
like oh they gave you benadryl you
knocked out and we had to drag you up
the stairs and take you home and I just
found out that I was allergic to toradol
that day which is a liquid Advil so I
told her about that whole hand and the
angels thing she told me that she was in
the corner of the doctors room and she
was praying for angels to come and save
me and do all this fun stuff said get me
out of what was going on so we never
ended up figuring out what happened or
why the painting was there I never felt
the pain again I guess it kind of worked
out and that's my er horror story
[Music]